it's six o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
pressure grows on the pm over his
delayed suspension of chris pincher with
new claims of inappropriate behavior
against the former tory deputy chief
whip stretching back a decade
the transport secretary presses ahead
with plans to speed up security checks
for new staff at airports as a new wave
of cancellations looms
in ukraine russia launches an all-out
assault on the eastern city of lesiansk
as an adviser to president zielenski
says the city could fall in the coming
days
the palestinian authority says it has
given the bullet that killed al jazeera
journalist shirin abu akhle to us
forensic experts in an attempt to
resolve her death
left in limbo by the taliban girls in
afghanistan still don't know if or when
they'll be allowed to go to
school campaigners call for more
awareness around muscle dysmorphia as a
growing number of men struggle to deal
with their body image
plus we'll have the latest sports news
including from wimbledon where nick
curios and stefanos sidsipas played out
one of the most ill-tempered and
controversial matches in the
tournament's history
and we'll be taking a look at the papers
with author and broadcaster emma wolf
and journalist and author nikki hodge
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast pressure is growing on the
prime minister over his delayed
suspension of the conservative party
deputy chief whip chris pincher mr
pincher was suspended by the party after
allegations he groped two men at a
private members club but only after an
official investigation was launched
boris johnson is now facing claims in
the sunday papers he turned a blind eye
to accusations against mr pincher's
behavior which stretched back a decade
it comes as mps who were at the event on
wednesday night told sky news chris
pincher was quote incredibly drunk and
beyond the limit sky's chief political
correspondent john craig has the latest
from westminster
disgraced chris pincher was incredibly
drunk on the night he's alleged to have
groped two men
mps present at the carlton club that
evening have told sky news
he was beyond the limit when he should
be socializing one mp told me he was
slurring and mumbling some nonsense and
he came back in saying he needed the lou
after he was asked to leave
asked if he'd seen mr pincher drunk
before the mp told me not that bad he
was incredibly drunk
in his first public statement since he
lost the tory whip mr pincher admitted
he drank far too much on wednesday night
and is now seeking medical support
one mp told me that it was uh 1am when
mr pinscher eventually left the club
after the bar had closed
these new revelations coincide with
increasing pressure on boris johnson
over his handling of the chris pincher
controversy and claims that he turned a
blind eye when he appointed him to the
sensitive post of deputy chief whip in
february this year
the sunday telegraph reports that he
turned a blind eye to sex pest warnings
about mr pincher the sunday mirror says
he was warned twice and the independent
is claiming that a conservative mp
alleges he was groped twice by mr
pincher
and the mail on sunday reporting a claim
first made by mr johnson's former
advisor dominic cummings says mr johnson
knew about mr pincher two years ago and
told aides he's handsy that's a problem
pincher by name pinscher by nature
well the fallout around chris pincher no
doubt is going to be one of the topics
discussed on this week's surface on
sunday sophie's guests this morning
include the work in pension secretary
terese coffey and labour's shadow
business secretary jonathan reynolds
coming up live at 8 30 this morning
well in other news the government is
battling to tame the chaos at airports
across the country by speeding up
security checks for new staff it comes
as british airways and heathrow prepare
to announce a new wave of flight
cancellations to try to ease strain on
airports over the summer holidays ba
says reducing the schedule at heathrow
this summer will offer certainty to
customers and avoid last-minute
cancellations matthew thompson reports
the traditional british summer break is
fast becoming a summer breakdown
cancelled flights delayed baggage
holidays in ruins
rob and his wife samantha were due to be
celebrating their anniversary in spain's
costa del sol when we found out the
flight spin council we were incredibly
disappointed
we had restaurant bookings we had
various things planned during the course
of the weekend
all of which obviously
was completely ruined
and
our initial thought was to simply simply
go back home and
have a celebration in the uk it's a very
special weekend we'd organized planned
various things in malaga
and
incredibly upset
to make matters worse a fueling system
failure ground heathrow to a halt on
saturday causing major delays
and a wave of further cancellations is
expected this week ahead of a government
deadline on friday part of what's been
called a slot amnesty
at airports like heathrow flight traffic
is governed by a strict system of
takeoff and landing slots in a typical
week heathrow might have something like
9680 slots or 690 departures a day of
those british airways owns more than 50
percent the next biggest airline virgin
atlantic only has four percent but
crucially if an airline doesn't use its
slots it must hand them back
they're highly prized i mean at heathrow
they change hands when they very rarely
come up uh for millions of pounds and so
airlines don't want to give up these
slots and so often they will commit to
running flights which they can't
feasibly operate
but this is a temporary measure and the
government is saying we'll give you an
amnesty on those slots we'll hand them
back to you at the end of summer season
so you won't lose them in the long term
aside from friday's deadline the wider
causes of the airport chaos are complex
the primary issue is disruption from the
pandemic having cut jobs when air travel
was shut down the industry has been slow
to fill them again in time to meet
surging demand airlines like easyjet and
ryanair have blamed brexit and the uk's
stricter immigration rules something the
government rejects and then there's the
prospect of looming strike action which
threatens to make matters a great deal
worse
british airways staff at heathrow have
just voted to strike at some point in
the summer threatening more chaos to try
and lessen the disruption the department
for transport has announced it's
speeding up the hiring process by
vetting airport staff more quickly
so if you are planning a holiday the
best advice might be to in the words of
your cabin crew brace brace matthew
thompson sky news
well to ukraine now we're an advisor to
president vladimir zelinsky has claimed
the fate of the embattled city of liza
schansk will be decided in the next two
days
sky news visited the city earlier in the
week with russian forces now stepping up
their assault in an all-out attempt to
seize the last stronghold of resistance
in the eastern luhansk province after
neighboring zferra donetsk fell to the
russians a week ago ukrainian fighters
have been trying to defend the city
well two british men have been charged
and accused of being mercenaries by
separatists loyal to the kremlin in
ukraine dylan healey and andrew hill
were captured in the eastern donbass
region by the self-proclaimed donetsk
people's republic the foreign office has
condemned the exploitation of prisoners
of war and says it is supporting the
pair's families sally lockwood reports
now from kiev
another two british citizens captured by
russian forces charged with being
mercenaries
22 year old dylan healey from
cambridgeshire was reportedly working as
an aid volunteer when he was seized with
another british citizen
thirty-five-year-old andrew hill from
plymouth understood to be a father of
four and a former british soldier was in
ukraine volunteering with the military
they were both arrested in april and are
being held in the so-called donetsk
people's republic a breakaway region in
eastern ukraine that's been fighting
ukrainian forces since 2014.
stanislav sev was held by the same group
for two and a half years until he was
released in a prisoner swap in 2019.
he refers to the prison he was at as a
concentration camp
i was in in israel for 28 months so
all i see is a torture for every day not
only for me it's only for it's also for
for women
for women in the
end and men and it was
it was terrible were you tortured yes i
am
the electricity by the twist
optimistic any british prisoners may be
treated differently
than mr healey and mr hill are facing
the same mercenary charges as aiden
aslan and sean pinner who were sentenced
to the death penalty in june
sky news met the two british men in the
trenches before their arrests they'd
been living in ukraine and maintained
they were legitimately serving with the
country's military
the foreign office has said we condemn
the exploitation of prisoners of war and
civilians for political purposes and
have raised this with russia we are in
constant contact with the government of
ukraine on their cases and are fully
supportive of ukraine in its efforts to
get them released
it's understood up to 100 foreign
nationals have been taking prisoner in
this war so far
but one organization working in aid in
ukraine
says the arrests of british citizens are
being far more widely publicized
it's showing that russia has a
seeing britain as a big ally to ukraine
and this and therefore using uh british
prisoners as a way of
maybe negotiating but also using very
political tools
earlier this week ukraine announced the
largest exchange of prisoners of war
since russia invaded securing the
release of 144 of its soldiers
it seems there's far more political
capital in holding british prisoners and
there's great concern over their fate
sally lockwood sky news keeve
the palestinian authority says it has
given the bullet that killed al jazeera
journalist shirin abu aklai to u.s
forensic experts in an attempt to
resolve her death the
palestinian-american journalist was
fatally shot while covering an israeli
military raid in may in the jenin
refugee camp in the occupied west bank
last month the un human rights office
says its findings suggest sharing about
was killed by israeli forces but the
israeli army says that she was caught in
the crossfire of a battle with
palestinian gunmen and that it is
impossible to determine which side
killed her without analyzing the bullet
abortion rights protesters have clashed
with pro-life demonstrators and police
in new york following the u.s supreme
court's decision to overturn roe versus
wade last week the new york police
department can be seen forming a
blockade between the two opposing sides
in an attempt to limit any violence no
arrests have been made demonstrations
were also held in texas cincinnati and
chicago
bruce johnson's 2019 election pledged to
build 40 new hospitals by 2030 is facing
a review by the government's official
spending watchdog the national audit
office is planning a value for money
review that could consider increasing
costs and whether the hospitals will in
fact be new the announcement comes after
les bouchard labour shadow health
secretary west streeting asked for an
investigation into the delays
surrounding the program
protesters in libya have blocked roads
and set tars ablaze as they rallied
against worsening living conditions and
years of political chaos there has been
unrest in the country since the 2011
uprising which saw colonel muammar
gaddafi ousted competing factions in the
east and west of the country are divided
on a constitutional framework for
national elections
thousands are also protesting in sudan
where nine people have been killed
following demonstrations against the
country's military rule the north
african nation has been experiencing
near weekly protests
after an october coup up ended its
fragile transition to democracy
let's have a look at the front pages of
this morning's papers now here they are
the telegraph these were with reports
that the prime minister's decision to
appoint chris pincher to help oversee
party discipline prompted the
resignation of craig whitaker another
senior whip
the sunday times is also leading on the
latest upset after speaking to an
anonymous source who claims they were
groped by chris pincher
the sunday mirror claims mr johnson
missed chances to investigate mr
pinscher after being warned about the
deputy chief whip's behavior
the observer
it reports that the government's
official spending watchdog is to launch
that inquiry into the prime minister's
claim that 40 new hospitals will be
built by 2030.
the express claims a cabinet battle is
underway with ministers urging boris
johnson to cut taxes now
the daily star tells brits to wash less
oh that's nice too
especially in the heat ah no well it's
to avoid water shortages as hot weather
is no don't listen to that please for
everyone's sake
and just a reminder for you we have a
new program for you this weekend you can
watch the climate show with tom heap
here on sky news 3 30 p.m and 7 30 p.m
today and every saturday and sunday
now campaigners are calling for more
awareness around muscle dysmorphia the
condition also known as bigarexia is
where someone feels their body frame is
much smaller than it actually is
sadly the consequences are both physical
and psychological as causalization
finding out
at times george has been obsessed with
the way he looks
as a teenager he gained weight after he
broke his back
he's gone to extremes to control it
started going into the fitness industry
and the fitness community and i saw that
all the guys in that world were big
muscular covered in veins six packs and
you know all that stuff so i thought
that's what i had to adhere to that's
where i needed to go and then that kind
of pursuit came from there and that's
when i took on like disordered eating
and exercise addiction and i was
training unbelievable amounts of times
and being incredibly restrictive with
how i ate and eventually it led to these
kind of like suicidal behaviors and
suicidal ideations and and yeah let down
this dark path
george has muscle dysmorphia he thinks
he's less muscular than he actually is
he says the picture-perfect culture on
social media has played its part and a
new report has found that a third of
young british men say they need to
change their appearance because of it
there's lots of pressure
um from social media to trying to
conform to certain
stereotypes of an idealized beauty
and i think particularly in men this is
something that's a real challenge
because
um there's a we're probably a bit in a
way a bit less used to it than women are
we're more recently exposed to these
kinds of pressures and regretfully women
have been exposing for a lot longer
but also there's very little movement at
the moment against
pressure on men
one surgeon says that pressure is
leading some to abuse steroids which can
cause breast growth
as a result he's performing hundreds of
breast reductions on men every year if
you take a look at what's playing right
now what is it love island right now if
you turn it on every guy on there has a
six pack his chest is up to here pecks
and everything are blowing out of their
shirts and so guys are seeing this and
they want to emulate these are their
heroes just like in the 80s when you had
the you know sylvester stallone and
arnold schwarzenegger
that pursuit of so-called perfection is
something george may always need
counselling for but he's in a better
place now and working to raise awareness
of the problem
lisa dowd sky news
let's have a quick check on the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it'll turn much drier from monday
although the northwest can still expect
rain at times but it'll be quite showery
again today it's mostly fine dry and
mild now but there's a scattering of
showers in the north and west
showers will spread to most parts this
morning but they'll be fairly isolated
over ireland and northern ireland where
they'll mostly die out by midday it'll
be a bit warmer than yesterday and not
as windy but the northwest will see the
wind strengthening just a little bit a
little later on
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning you're watching sky news
breakfast our top stories this morning
pressure is growing on boris johnson
over his delayed suspension of chris
pincher with new claims of inappropriate
behaviour emerging against the former
tory debt chief
the government is speeding up security
checks for new staff at uk airports as
british airways and heathrow prepare to
announce a new wave of flight
cancellations
and in ukraine russia launches an
all-out assault on the eastern city of
lysyshansky as an advisor to president
zielenski says the city could fall in
the coming days
girls aged 12 and older in afghanistan
still don't know if or when they'll be
allowed to go to school
the taliban banned teenage girls going
to school when they came to power in
august last year and they were expected
to announce whether or not they would
allow those girls back to secondary
school this weekend but as the male only
grand council meeting in kabul came to
an end
no announcement was made
our correspondent insman rashid reports
now from kabul
for two teenage girls in afghanistan
this is what school looks like
learning from each other in their
bedrooms not a classroom
ilaha and el hammer should both be in
secondary school studying for crucial
exams but it was a taliban u-turn which
has left them denied a basic human right
that one is very bad moment sad moment
because we need
education
in future we have life we have
in future we need the job
and on the final day of the grand
council meeting where 3 000 taliban
followers all men gathered to discuss
and announce policy there was no
announcement about girls and education
every girl's allowed to school and they
will education but that's not true now
i don't understand
who can live
and how do you make these girls
understand when it comes to finishing
sixth grade they'll be back home with
limited opportunities it's a policy that
is painful for teachers too
we are not the womans of 20 years ago
and they want to
calm all
womans and they we with this saying that
today we open the school tomorrow we
open the school but nothing at the end
nothing they want to cheat all the women
of afghanistan
but the taliban today adamant they'll
fulfill their promise
what do you say directly
to girls millions of girls across
afghanistan tonight who are crying who
are disappointed because you haven't
allowed them to go to school
islamic
this could have been a pivotal moment
for the taliban's position in the eyes
of the world but many governments will
take note of their lack of inclusivity
and worsening track record on human
rights
but the condemnation wasn't just from
the international community it's come
from local leaders in afghanistan too
many believe it's against islam to stop
girls from attending school
and now with no announcement the
pressure on the taliban here in the
country and across the world
is intensifying
[Music]
once again at the heart of today's
political decision-making are millions
of young women and girls for whom hope
is in short supply interval rasheed sky
news
kabul now it may sound daunting but a
50-year mortgage may soon be an option
in the uk the government is considering
plans so that children could inherit the
debt from their parents home in an
attempt to tackle the housing crisis
aisha zahid has been investigating
like so many elizabeth struggled getting
onto the property ladder when close to
buying price hikes got in the way her
only option was to move further away
from home to alleviate these kind of
problems the government's considering
multi-generational 50-year mortgages
something elizabeth doesn't agree with
a 50-year mortgage
is practically rented
because the bank more or less owns your
house passing a debt
to my children
on an asset
is
it doesn't i don't see how it adds value
to them so young
i think it puts them in a place of more
financial stress and financial
responsibility when they're just
starting their lives
they may not be simple and
straightforward but here's how
longer-term mortgages could help
well it's not just first-time buyers who
struggle with affordability it's also
those looking to move to bigger homes
maybe to start a family so being able to
put mortgage over a longer term will
help them push down the monthly payments
or possibly even borrow that a little
bit more
and maintain an affordable monthly cost
to the mortgage it's clear there are
risks to balance with benefits but the
opposition says alternatives need to be
addressed is to make sure we're building
more genuinely affordable homes
reforming the credit market to make sure
that uh that people can afford to get on
the housing ladder and addressing the
real issues that we're seeing in surging
house prices developers land banking
properties
councils and housing associations not
having the resources to build the
affordable housing that we need they're
the steps that should be taken the
government says it's committed to
tackling the housing crisis a
spokesperson said we will be undertaking
the first comprehensive review of the
mortgage market for a decade on top of
this we're also investing 11.5 billion
pounds to build more of the affordable
quality homes this country needs
for now 50-year mortgages are only one
idea but they certainly won't be the
final solution aisha zahid sky news
there are now more people aged 65 and
over in england and wales than ever
before and there's a growing number who
are still working once they reach
retirement age for some it's because
they need the income for others they're
just not ready to stop fraser moored
reports
when shashi agarwal stopped running the
family business over a decade ago she
thought she'd finished work but boredom
set in and mama spice was born now she's
one of the increasing number of
unretired as she concentrates on growing
the spice kitchen brand with her family
i wouldn't say it was a thought which we
thought it's going to become big it was
just to keep ourselves occupied
me and my husband to keep us occupied
uh during the daytime which we had
plenty of time to do
and we have never sat and done nothing
in our life so 38 running a business was
quite a tough job
so we wanted to continue that
not as a full-time job but just a
retirement little hobby
but it
didn't stay hobby for very long
it just became now quite a big business
shashi's found a way to monetize her
passion for food and in the process turn
what was a retirement hobby into a
thriving business but not all retirees
are as fortunate or as entrepreneurial
so lots of pensioners are finding it
really difficult to make ends meet at
the moment uh obviously the cost of
living crisis is causing huge problems
for people and for some pensioners that
have may have the ability to go back out
to work and earn a bit of extra money
which undoubtedly some people will do
but for other pensioners it's really
tough and we need to make sure the
government is continuing to support
people through these difficult times
according to a new survey two-thirds of
people retiring this year won't give up
work completely that's almost double the
number from just two years ago a quarter
of them plan to work part time one in
six will work for themselves and over 10
percent plan to start a new business
on the streets of york those who have
already retired seem to be loving life
those who aren't are still a little
unsure about what the future may bring
i wouldn't mind going um freelance maybe
he's working three days a week but i
can't see without retiring till
67 70. i loved work don't get me wrong i
actually enjoyed work but from the
moment i walked out the gate
loved it off i probably would do a sort
of a phased retirement just because um
i've worked all my life and i can
imagine
i just would want something to keep me
occupied
now in her 70s shashi's full-time
retirement could still be a long way off
she's now building another business
around her other main passion
sewing
fraser moored sky news
tens of thousands of people gathered in
london yesterday for pride the parade
followed the footsteps of the original
1972 march and marks 50 years since that
first event in the half century since
then there's been huge social change but
for those present at the beginning of
the movement there is still much left to
do here's katie spencer
equality and inclusion lie at the heart
of prize
and while everyone is invited to the
party this year some were more welcome
than others
what a small number of the metropolitan
police were on hand to provide security
serving officers were asked not to march
in uniform as activists hit out about
homophobia in the force including
failings and how it handled the
investigation into the serial killer
stephen port there's a lot of
institutionalized issues that we have to
address
and you know organizations like
metropolitan police really can go out
and do their community engagement
after two-year high ages because of the
pandemic you can tell from these crowds
just how excited people are for the
return of pride and while it is a
celebration of the milestones that have
been achieved in the last 50 years it's
also a reminder that it isn't all
rainbow flags and glitter
[Music]
amongst the thousands of supporters
a reminder that religious bigotry still
exists but the prime minister giving the
march his approval writing how it gives
him the greatest pride to lead a country
where you can love whomever you choose
to love
he is proposing a ban on conversion
therapy that will not protect trans
people he won't reform the gender
recognition act he is still supporting
the detention in prison-like conditions
of lgbt plus refugees who are fleeing
persecution abroad until he makes those
changes those are hollow words
asked to lead the parade veteran
campaigners who marched these streets
fifty years ago four or five hundred
people with just as many police looking
very povos
on either side um very disgruntled that
they were having to march with these
people who were deviants
in my own choir
the guy who was organizing our pride
mart was attacked by homophobes last
night and ended up in hospital with his
boyfriend that shows if anything shows
at all that what we're doing today is
absolutely relevant
a snapshot of a movement and a
conversation that has completely evolved
over the last 50 years but casting a
shadow over this explosion of color that
in 2022 the lgbt plus community is still
facing discrimination
[Applause]
casey spencer sky news
time for a quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it will turn much drier from monday
although the northwest can still expect
rain at times but it'll be quite showery
again today it's mostly fine dry and
mild now but there's a scattering of
showers in the north and west
showers will spread to most parts this
morning but they'll be fairly isolated
over ireland and northern ireland where
they'll mostly die out by midday
it will be a bit warmer than yesterday
and not as windy but the northwest will
see the wind strengthening a little
later on
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
still to come here on sky news breakfast
we're going to be reviewing the papers
with the author and broadcaster emma
wolfe and the journalist and author
nikki hodgston
[Music]
hello again you're watching sky news
breakfast time to have a look through
the papers with us to do that the author
and broadcaster emma wolf and journalist
and author nikki hodgson good morning to
you both thank you so much for getting
up early on a sunday morning and joining
us let's kick off with the mirror nikki
um
let's have a look let's bring it up
okay so boris missed chances to probe
pinscher jonah just talk us through that
yeah so this is an exclusive by nigel
nelson and it is basically explaining
that
boris johnson was aware apparently of
the allegations against chris pincher
first because mps brought this to his
attention they made complaints about him
and then secondly because a group of
staffers also did and they actually set
up their own campaign group and wrote
the pm about their concerns on may the
24th so this was a couple of weeks after
neil parish resigned that he was the
tory mp that was caught watching porn in
the house of commons and um it just kind
of just kind of beggars belief because
what seems to keep happening in the tory
party is that people keep uh doing these
things that are you know pretty
egregious that in any other workplace
they would be in a lot of trouble for
doing and if not sacked immediately and
yet there seems to be a delay in dealing
with these allegations with these rumors
and it's just not good enough really
frankly
okay emma um let's have a look at the
telegraph as well because they've also
got this story um and they say that
another senior whip actually resigned
when um the prime minister appointed mr
fincher
the allegations in the telegraph are
pretty serious as well just adding to
what nikki said there um apparently back
in february when chris pincher was was
um
appointed um there was
you know general awareness of the
allegations of previous allegations
against him we've seen more and more of
them coming out over this weekend
um
and actually they were so serious the
allegations that another another whip in
the wips office um chris whittaker
actually resigned over this so it was
obviously a serious matter back as far
back as 2020 kimberley the prime
minister allegedly made a joke about
chris pincher being rather handsy and he
said pincher by name pincher by nature
i think this really does call into
question the prime minister of judgement
on this we've seen this before this drip
drip of the truth coming out about
something and obviously this matter is
still under investigation
but we've seen this with partygate we've
seen it with the owen patterson affair
when boris johnson defended owen
patterson against
probably his better judgment probably
against good advice so i think this
affair is extremely damaging not only
for
chris pincher himself and the people
involved but for boris johnson and for
his you know for his judgment
yeah um nikki what do you think how
damaging do you think this could all be
for the pm i mean it's in most of the
papers isn't it
well there's a very practical point that
if chris pincher is to resign that will
trigger a by-election in town with his
constituency and obviously we've seen
what's happened in wakefield recently
and uh you know
they just the tourists cannot afford to
lose another by-election but it's very
very tricky for boris johnson because if
he lets chris pincher stay in position
he's going to be seen to not tackle the
problem and if there is a by-election
triggered that could be the beginning of
the end of the tory party in power and
very much start to hand over power to
labour or even the lib dems come the
next general election
do you think well broadly emma this
again asks questions again about the
culture at westminster and what it's
like to actually work there
i really do kimberly this is my main
beef with this story is not
specifically what happened on wednesday
night but the fact that someone in the
middle of a working week can be by his
own admission
so drunk you know people say that he was
on it you know almost unable to speak
that he was literally sort of falling
all over the place
okay it wasn't on the palace of
westminster premises you know there are
lots of bars in westminster we know that
but it was you know a senior member of
the government who is working drinking
that much and then presumably expecting
to go into work on thursday these are
serious times we need serious people and
i think the drinking culture quite apart
from the allegations about groping and
and sleeves i think the drinking culture
needs to be looked at because i don't
want people serving us who are going
trying to operate with a stonking
hangover and really not functioning at
their best we know what alcohol does and
it doesn't serve you well
okay let's um let's turn to the observer
now um and this is all about that
the claim by the pm that 40 new
hospitals i think that's the key isn't
it that there were going to be new
hospitals were going to be built by
2030. um there's the watchdog is
launching an inquiry isn't it nikki
yeah so the official spending watchdog
the national audit office is
investigating this claim by boris
johnson that 40 new hospitals were to be
built by 2030. the reason being because
actually on examination of the detail
what it seems is that there are new
wings of hospitals being built there are
refurbishments being done but there are
not 40 new hospitals so it's actually
sounds like it's very misleading
and um you know the problem with this is
that this was actually a cornerstone
policy of the 2019 conservative party uh
general election manifesto this pledge
for 40 new hospitals so if it turns out
that it's not to be true or it's been an
exaggeration of the truth yet again it
calls into question boris johnson's
judgment his integrity um his ability to
tell the truth about all kinds of
matters and and yet again it's just you
know it's just very damning for him
let's have a look at the express emma
because this is um well this
claims that there's a cabinet battle
underway and in many ways this isn't a
great uh headline for boris johnson
either is it boris told we need tax cuts
now
he's not getting great headlines at the
moment at all he just can't be right for
doing wrong yeah so this is apparently
really a cabinet battle is underway with
the pro tax cutting people saying to to
the prime minister and to the chancellor
rishi sunak look we need tax cuts now
they're saying the british people are
not fools you know if you suddenly roll
out tax cuts before the next election
that's just going to be seen as a
pre-election gimmick
and also if tax cuts they say if tax
cuts are good for the economy and good
for the cost of living crisis then they
should happen as soon as possible
um and you know these calls are coming
from across the across the tory party
from left and right they're coming from
people like ian duncan smith john
redwood damian green and many others um
and they really feel that something
needs to be done sooner rather than
later to actually help people with the
with the looming cost of living crisis
nikki what do you think because you know
for the past two weeks he's been on the
world stage you know really where the pm
is in his element and he's always
champion whenever he's asked about
what's happening at home he's always
championed the line oh we're doing
everything we can to help people um
but do you think
more needs to be done and we do need to
see these tax cuts
well the thing is the very fact that
we're having strike action indicates
just how annoyed people are with the
situation
and the the fact is that promising tax
cuts that will also come next year which
is one of the headlines that we had last
week it's too little too late so you
know the cost of living crisis needs to
be tackled now or the tories will lose
the general election on it
really do you think they will emma what
do you think do you think they'll lose
it on that
i think that
look i'm not going to predict who knows
who knows anything these days
who knows when it's going to be kimberly
but i mean who knows what's going to
happen in the next two years i would be
a fool to predict it but i think
definitely that we need to target to
help to people more
more in a smarter way i think something
will be done and something needs to be
done um but if they lose the next
election there are quite a lot of things
they could be losing it on
okay let's have a look at
what is it um the times
such a great picture let's have a look
yes there we go um
fried parade in london 50 years
it's it's interesting to look back and
think okay 50 years has passed but
it's quite troubling to think that so
much more actually needs to be done
doesn't it
yeah absolutely i mean it's a fantastic
picture i think it was a fantastic day
out for lots of people yesterday
and um you know it's very important to
remember that the pride parade itself
has been quite contentious over the past
few years pride london has had
difficulties with the organizing then
there was the pandemic so it's wonderful
to see such a big turnout and it's very
special to london i think his pride
but i think what is disturbing is the
fact that we are still debating some key
issues around equality particularly
around trans rights you know there is
the conversion therapy bill which does
not include the protection of trans
people as peter tatcher pointed out in
your report and just in general boris
johnson seems to not always
get to grips with the the matter of
trans rights and the fact that people
are just kind of waiting for full
equality in a way that instead there are
still debates about you know the cabinet
office and uh civil servants using
language which excludes women for
example it's very very thorny and very
very difficult the arguments uh around
trans rights at the moment but the boris
transform really needs to fully tackle
them it's interesting that theresa may
came out this week and said that
actually given her time again she would
vote differently on some key issues of
equality yeah equality at the end of the
day that's what it's about uh the most
troubling thing for me in the papers
we've got very short time to do it emma
why are we being told to wash less
wash less do less laundry so this is the
promised heat wave and i don't know
where it is because it keeps being
promised
we've got 20 seconds 20 seconds it's not
a barbecue summer anymore it's a bikini
summer so to to avoid water shortages we
need to wash less and do less laundry
the way bikini is watch less where do
you it's all i can say